AND THEY'LL NEED IT IN GAME
NIEDERREITER.
BUT NIEDR PULLS THE PUCK
UP THE WALL, GETS INSIDE
SKJEI BACK DOWN TO
HEAL.
HE HAS HAD SUCCESS IN THE
11 PO
GAMES FOR IS LAUGH.
SHAKING HIS HEAD AWAY ONE
>> Gord: KOTK.
TWO-ON-ONE FOR CAROLINA AS
STEPAN MOVES IN, CHABOT BACK ON
HIM, STEPAN IFPOINT, CAN DOWNN S
HOLDEN A SHOT, GOES OFF THE
STICK OF DeANGELO. AND THE PUCK
AND FOOLED FREDERIK ANDERSEN.
PAUL STEPS OFF THE
SATURDAY. AFERENT ENDS
HELPED OT
MATT MURRAY.
AND HE'S HAD AULD WORK
TOGETHER THAT WAY.
>> Gord: AHO'S AGENT IS THE JUS
PERFECT
SANFORD, IN ON , WALKS
IN, SHOOTS, IS CRAIG, AN
OTTAWA DRAFTSTAAL, COULDN'T
2023.
PUT I
TROCHECK, JOSH BROWN STAYS WITH
FI
GOAL.
TIED UP BY OU HAVE
A IN COMES TO TUCK
IT IN.IN, SHOOTS, AND MURRAY S !
>> Mike: SHORT SIDE.
AN FIVE-HE AT
ALL OF IT HE'S JUST TRYING TO O
SCORES!
THAT GIVES C C